où on veut et avec nous pour ce club
bonjour if trèard merci d'être avec nous
bonjour à tous comme tous les lundis
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro Marcial fouco est avec nous
bonjour martial merci d'être la
politologue directeur du cvipof et on va
revenir sur l'interview de David
lissnard à l'instant alors que se tient
cette semaine le Congrès des Maires de
France et Martial vous avez réalisé une
grande enquête auprès des maires engagés
mais pas empêché on va en parler dans
quel état d'esprit sont les maires
aujourd'hui quelle réponse attend-il
c'est la Une du Figaro c'est votre
enquête martial on va en parler tout de
suite Alex don les chiffres oui et
notamment des chiffres records de
violences qui sont subies par ses
mairres et ses élus locaux on en parle
dans quelques instant d'abord c'est
l'actualité dans nos
[Musique]
régions et l'actualité dans nos régions
en Vendé les maires qui ont été élus en
2020 sont aujourd'hui à miandat un
mandat qui a débuté en pleine crise
sanitaire et qui se tient dans un
contexte difficile avec une augmentation
des incivilités voir des agressions
alors comment les maires ont-ils vécu
ces trois dernières années nos
partenaires de TV Vendé sont allés à la
rencontre de deux d'entre eux on regarde
le reportage il est signé Alexandre
Naour être un élu aujourd'hui mais à
quel prix une mission en proie aux
incivilités et en pleine mutation depuis
plusieurs années anne-emarie Coulon
présidente des mères de vendet a bien
Notter ces différents changements on est
euh sous les dossiers il y a un dossier
par jour qui qui sort ou une une
directive administrative donc c'est
lourd administrativement de gérer tout
ça la difficulté aussi dans les mission
de d'élus c'est le manque de
reconnaissance la maire de mousœil
Saint-Martin constate aussi que beaucoup
d'élus jettent l'éponge depuis 2020 et
les dernières élections municipal nous
sommes à entre 100 et 150 démissions
dont une quinzaine de MRES quelques
décès mais quand même c'est un chiffre
que nous n'avions jamais eu il y a qui
ont démissionné en effet parce que la
tâche était trop lourde et que au niveau
de l'équipe équipe ça ne marchait plus
ils n'ont pas su peut-être trouver leur
place et puis on va peut-être avoir ce
caslà en deuxième partie de mandat de
Mair qui ont déjà fait leur temps et qui
prépareent la suite dans le haocage
vendé1 à pousoge Michel devan en place
depuis 2014 a ainsi choisi de ne pas se
représenter en 2026 aucune lassitude de
la fonction mais après 19 ans dans
l'opposition et de mandats de maire
cette enseignante à la retraite pense
déjà au passage de témoins lorsque j'ai
décidé de me présenter en 2020 je savais
que c'était pour 6 ans et qu'ensuite je
m'arrêterai ça fera 12 ans et pour moi
12 ans c'est suffisant qu'est-ce que
nous allons laisser derrière nous nous
sommes des passeurs et je crois que
maintenant il faut passer donc il faudra
donc quelqu'un d'autre poursuivre Michel
devan a vu cette mission évoluer une
activité chronophage qui peut aussi à
terme être la cause d'une certaine crise
de la vocation c'est plus difficile pour
nos jeunes élus qui travaillent parce
que il y a beaucoup beaucoup de réunions
qui ont lieu dans la journée et ils ont
du mal à y assister il faut que nous
puissions les garder ils sont l'avenir
plus le temps passe et plus ça devient
difficile pour un jeune d'être investi
et dans un contexte difficile la mèire
de cette petite cité de caractère lassû
être maire n'est pas un métier c'est une
mission moi je pense que donc on a une
vraie mission et quand on se présente à
une élection municipale c'est volontaire
à partir du moment où on l'a choisi bah
je crois qu'il faut assumer s'attacher à
inclure les habitants dans les décisions
et s'arrêter à temps pour ne pas
atteindre l'usure d'un mandat de trop
quelques pistes pour raviver une
vocation au service de l'intérêt général
et voilà pour ce sujet de TV vendet
assez révélateur de l'état d'esprit des
maires on va longuement parler de votre
enquête martial d'abord avant de voir
les résultats il y a un très grand
nombre d'élus qui ont répondu oui cette
année c'est historique on a mis en sur
pied ce dispositif en 2018 et cette
année 8000 maires ont répondu
partiellement à l'enquête qui était très
longue 70 questions plus de 40 minutes
de d'entretien et donc nous avons 6000
maires qui ont répondu en totalité et
puis nous avons innovation cette année
interroger également des adjoints on a
plus de 3500 adjoints au maire qui ont
accepté de répondre d'ailleurs on voit
globalement que la position des adjoints
et celle des maires est assez semblable
et donc il partage sensiblement à la
fois les mêmes difficultés mais aussi
parfois les mêmes satisfaction c'est la
5è enquête de ce type que vous faites
est-ce que l'état d'esprit des maires a
évolué quand on a démarré en 2018 nous
n'avions connu ni le mouvement gilet
jaune ni la crise covid ni la crise
inflationniste ni la crise énergétique
donc oui depuis 5 ans je dirais que ces
différentes couches de de de difficulté
se sont rajouté à l'état d'esprit des
maires et puis je rappelle un point qui
est important on les interroge cette
année en 2023 on est à mi-parcours sur
cette mandature et en général j'observe
que euh la le le miandat est un point
critique un peu de bascule où un certain
nombre de mer se disent 3 ans c'est
beaucoup trop et le reportage le montre
hein maintenant il est temps de passer
la main ou bien je m'attendais pas à
l'empleur de la tâche hein qui qui est
la l'heure et donc c'est le moment où on
commence beaucoup à réfléchir à ne pas
se représenter à passer la main et aussi
à démissionner puisque c'est un sujet
qui qu' on a essayé de traiter sur les
causes dans l'enquête et on va en parler
Yve la grande inquiétude des mes de
France c'est le titre que vous avez
choisi ce matin la Une du Figaro pour
parler de l'ouverture de ce congrès ça
résume l'état d' bah ça résume
semble-t-il l'état d'esprit des mères
qui est reflété par cette enquête qui
est une belle enquête donc ça fait
longtemps qu'on dit que les maires il y
a une espèce de
fatigue j'allais dire municipale qui est
principalement dû à à deux choses si
j'ai bien compris la première et c'est
bien souligné dans le le documentaire
que vous dans le reportage que vous avez
montré c'est la la l'excès de
bureaucratie l'excès de de de de paperas
de plans qui sont imposé par l'État
central euh et la deuxème des causes
c'est aussi la les violences
effectivement l'incivisme qui grandit
alors ça se traduit par B une une espèce
de de chute de l'autorité des ma et
jusqu'à présent les maires étaient quand
même les élus les plus respectés et les
plus appréciés de la population et on
voit que leur code de popularité elle
reste élevée mais elle est quand même
déclinante et ça dit ça ça dit beaucoup
de choses de l'état du pays ça dit que
ben justement cette autorité qui est en
perdition sur la voie publique à l'école
dans l'entreprise partout et bien cette
autorité c'est aussi le ciment de notre
pacte républicain et si elle commence à
à s'effriter ben il y a de quoi
s'inquiéter
oui oui je confme ce que vient de dire
Yve c'est-à-dire que il y a le phénomène
certes des violences qui sont très varié
hein on va des incivilités quand même se
m sur 10 nous indiquent que depuis le
début de leur mandat en 2020 ils ont
connu des faits d'incivilité et au fond
l'incivisme ça sarronge effectivement
comme le disait sarronge à la fois
l'autorité morale du maire ça ronge sa
la représentation respectueuse qu'on
peut avoir à l'endroit du maire parce
qu'on se dit si cela est possible et
qu'il n'y a pas de sanction alors
pourquoi ne pas continuer et bien
souvent on on a pu observe que les
maires sont extrêmement
dubitatifs sur la manière de de
réamorcer une voix apaisé parce que la
société française et peut-être que c'est
ça aussi un des éléments de l'enquête il
y a pas de raison de penser qu'au niveau
local on est totalement protégé du
caractère de plus en plus conflictuel de
la relation des Français entre eux sur
tous les sujets et je dirais que
jusqu'en 2020 beaucoup de mer disaient
on on est encore entendu il suffit de
parler d' parfois il se il s improvisé
comme médiateur aujourd'hui ça ne suffit
plus pour beaucoup d'entre eux ces
élémentsl ne suffisent plus à apaiser
des situations très tendu sur des sujets
qui sont pas simplement clochem parce
que c'est parfois en rapport à l'état
des questions de permis de construire
droit d'usage passage et donc c'est des
sujets où le maire n'a pas toujours la
compétence pour apporter des réponses
immédiates et et il faut s'inquiéter
parce que regardez vous avez c'était
d'actualité ces dernières semaines les
concours d'entrée aux professions de de
de dans enseignant euh pas assez de
candidats pourquoi il y a pas assez de
candidats parce que c'est ce sont des
métiers aussi qui sont en chute libre
sur le plan de de la popularité
c'està-dire c'est des métiers qui sont
réputés aujourd'hui et bien qui n'ont
plus le même prestige dans l'autorité
remise en question et tout si en plus il
y a une crise démocratique avec de moins
en moins de candidats pour devenir maire
ou adjoint maire ou ou conseiller
municipal bah ça c'est c'est c'est je
dirais même c'est dangereux pour l'État
de notre pays Alex on va voir quelques
quelquesuns des des chiffres de cette
enquête he une enquête qui révèle une
hausse des démissions oui depuis les
dernières élections municipales en 2020
450 maires ont démissionné chaque année
c'est un chiffre assez élevé lors de la
précédente mandature on était plutôt sur
un rythme de 350 démissions de maire par
an parmi les causes possibles de ces
démission selon les maires qui ont été
interrogés une ex une exigence trop
forte des citoyens également des
relations difficiles entre les communes
et l'État la montée des violences bien
sûr et puis 4è raison de démission la
difficile conciliation entre le mandat
et la vie professionnelle et l'une des
causes de ces démission on l'a dit c'est
qu'il subissent de plus en plus de
violence et oui 69 % des maires qui ont
été interrogés dans cette enquête ont
subi des incivilités c'est 16 points de
plus qu'en 2020 39 % décl avoir été
victime d'injure ou d'insulte c'est 10 %
de plus qu'en 2020 et puis point aussi
intéressant
15 % des maires déclarent se sentir en
insécurité Marcel on va parler de
l'insécurité mais euh c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des agression envers les
élus incivilité et agression qui
augmente mais c'est pas la première
cause ce dont se se plaignent le plus
les mer c'est la trop forte exigence des
citoyens envers eux oui il y a au fond
il y a trois grandes causes le premier
vous avez raison regardan il y a une
exigence jugée trop grande de la part
des citoyens qui va de paire avec la
question des comportements nouveaux dans
les communes et donc qui peuvent
déboucher parfois sur des sur des
violences et cette exigence des citoyens
on l'avait observé après l'élection 2022
on avait observé beaucoup de mes nous
avaient dit cette cette campagne
présidentielle législative je vois des
citoyens qui ne sont plus en capacité de
parler de discuter
entre eux avec des opinions différentes
immédiatement ça débouche sur sur des
questions très conflictuelles et donc il
y a une conflictualisation de la société
française et puis la deuxème la deuxième
cause d'où le titre de de l'enquête des
Mair engagés mais empêché parce que il y
a un sentiment d'impuissance vis-à-vis
de ce qui est devenu aujourd'hui le
périmètre de l'action municipale des
compétences moindres qui se sont un peu
dissoutes latéralement avec les
intercommunalités centralement je crois
que David Isnard tout à l'heure rappelit
que il y a effectivement une sorte de je
crois qu'il emploie parfois l'expression
du supplice du garot c'est-à-dire que
oui ils sont sous perfusion d'un État
qui définit le montant des dotations et
je rappelle que c'est c'est un sujet on
n pas en France une culture politique de
la décentralisation on en est très très
loin même si on a célébré il y a
quelques mois les 40 ans de des lois de
décentralisation ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que un maire
dans dans son cotidien pour agir il n'a
pas véritablement une marge de manœuvre
pour élaborer un programme justifiant si
vous voulez un impôt local auquel toute
une population pourrait adhérer ou ne
pas adhérer hein c'est le jeu
démocratique et bien c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que les
maires sont quémandeurs de dotation et
que ce contrôle ce contrôle qui est
exercé par l'État est reflété dans
d'autres domaines qui rend la tâche
parfois compliquée des maires ils ont
sentiment que les services déconcentrés
de l'État ne sont pas mobilisés toujours
pour les accompagner mais davantage pour
les contrôler et et ça c'est un élément
extrêmement perturbant pour les maires
et qui justifie pour beaucoup d'ailleurs
de jeter les poes en se disant mais à
quoi
servons-nous oui sur ce pouvoir d'agir
hein oui bah c'est le problème si vous
voulez c'est que on demande tout tout et
n'importe quoi au maire aussi parce que
à à cette difficile cohabitation qui
devrait être une coopération entre
l'État central et les ma et je rejoins
ce que dit martial c'est qu'on est dans
un état définitivement jacobin enfin on
a quand même beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
à à faire cette
décentralisation euh à la rendre
opérante sans qu'il y ait de jalousie
sans qu'il y ait des arrière-pensées euh
politique regardez comment a été fait la
révision des régions ça a été fait
n'importe comment enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est tout c'est c'est ni fait ni
à faire ça n'a aucun euh ça n'a
l'objectif si c'est l'objectif d'être
efficace c'est c'est c'est tout le
contraire qui s'est produit et puis il y
a une deuxième chose aussi c'est que euh
il y a beaucoup de défaillance de l'État
et aujourd'hui les les maires mais ça a
toujours été un petit peu le cas sont un
peu comme des assistantes sociales aussi
hein il faut pas l'oublier c'estàdire
que tout est de leur faute euh tout est
de leur responsabilité plus exactement
or c'est pas vrai j'entendais David
Lisnard tout à l'heure parler de
l'insécurité notamment dans les villes
vous vous posiez la question sur les
polices municipales certes mais les
maires ne sont pas des shérifs on n'est
pas dans le Far West avec un maire
toutpuissant qui sort son pistolet enfin
faut faut faut faut faut spéfier de tout
ça aussi et et donc le
maire c'est c'est je dirais c'est un
métier extrêmement compliqué extrêmement
délicat alors que ce n'est pas un métier
précisément merci àoui c'est juste parce
que je rajouterai dans l'enquête on a
parlé pour la première fois on on a posé
une question sur le sentiment
d'insécurité on peut objectiver le
caractère violent dans dans des communes
le nombre de délits et on a fait ce
travail avec les données de la police
nationale et la gendarmerie en posant la
question sur le sentiment d'insécurité
15 % vous le rappeliez de maire se
disent en insécurité on essaie de
regarder à quel type de commune ou à
quel type de territoire cela
correspondait et bien effectivement
parce que le maire d'un point de vue
juridique c'est à la fois une autorité
de police administrative et un officier
de police judiciaire donc il peut
exercer un certain nombre de fonctions
mais beaucoup d'entre eux disent
maintenant je je je n'ai pas envie de
d'abuser de ce droit parce que je peux
prendre des risques sur le terrain et
donc ce qu'on observe c'est que dans les
territoires si vous voulez dans les
communes au-delà de 10000 habitants où
vous pouvez avoir des services de police
municipale le sentiment d'insécurité est
moins grand chez les maires donc ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est que ce
sentiment d'insécurité se développe à
mesure que les moyens d'exercice de
cette police administrative ne sont pas
au rendez-vous parce que le maire est
mis effectivement en première ligne de
ces situations et il ne sait pas
véritablement comment vont réagir ses
concitoyens ou parfois je crois que ce
weekend il eu beaucoup de fait révélés
de maire devant intervenir face à à des
situations de violence euh venant
d'individus qui n'appartiennent pas à la
commune qui sont parfois loin de la
commune et donc là ça crée véritablement
un désarroi malgré tout le travail et là
je crois que la gendarmerie nationale
très présente sur les territoires ruraux
fait un travail exceptionnel à la fois
de formation c'estàd vous vous rendez
compte en 2023 nous sommes aujourd'hui
conduit à inciter les maires à
participer à des ateliers parfois animés
par la gendarmie nationale parfois par
le Raid et parfois par le gignn pour
donner des réponses à ces élus qui
lorsque beaucoup d'entre eux se sont
engagés en 2020 ou avant ne pensaient
pas devoir être confronté à ce type de
situation Alex il y a aussi la question
des indemnités qui est posée dans cette
enquête et et les maires ils pensent que
leur indemnité n'est pas selon eux à la
hauteur de leur engagement oui un
engagement qui est fort première preuve
de cet engagement le temps qu'il
consacre à leur fonction de maire en
moyenne dans une petite commune un maire
consacre 25 he par semaine à sa fonction
et dans une commune de plus de 9000
habitants un maire s'y consacre 50 he
par semaine alors on précise que ces
chiffres varient aussi en fonction des
maires qui sont à la retraite et des
maires qui continuent à exercer une
activité professionnelle alors même si
l'argent n'est pas la première raison de
leur engagement et bien 48 % des maires
interrogés dans cette enquête jugent
leur indemnité insuffisantes dont 43 %
des maires des petites communes et 78 %
des maires des communes de plus de 9000
habitants on peut rappeler que cette
indemnité de maire et bien pour un maire
d'une commune de moins de 500 habitants
elle s'élève à une indemnité brute de 11
€ de l'heure c'est-à-dire au niveau du
smicoraire et pour un maire d'une
commune entre 50000 habitants et 100000
habitants et bien l'indemnité s'élève
environ au double ouais et David lisnar
le redit he des des maires qui pour la
plupart touchent une indemnité
inférieure au SMIC est-ce que et
pourtant ce sont les maires des petites
communes qui se plaignent le moins que
les maires des grandes communes martial
oui peut-être parce que en 2019 la loi
engagement et proximité a permis de
revaloriser l'indemnité des des maires
des communes de moins de 3500 habitants
alors évidemment ça a donné quelques
idées aux maires des communes de taille
supérieure et ça sera sans doute débattu
durant cette semaine au au Congrès des
Maires mais la question de l'indemnité
elle est elle est à la fois cruciale
parce que vous avez raison de rappeler
que beaucoup de maires disent on ne
s'engage pas pour gagner de l'argent
pour s'enrichir en revanche on ne veut
pas en perdre non plus et et c'est c'est
c'est un point important d'équilibre à
trouver parce que l'enquête rappelle que
60 % des maires aujourd'hui ont une
activité prof professionnelle en
parallèle et donc la conciliation d'une
vie professionnelle avec la fonction est
parfois compliquée certains décident de
renoncer à leur activité professionnelle
quelques mois après leur prise de
fonction parce qu'ils se rendent compte
qu'ils ne peuvent pas trouver une
organisation de vie compatible et donc
là ils se retrouve avec des baisses des
pertes de revenus considérables donc il
peut y avoir sur le sujet de la
revalorisation de l'indemnité peut-être
un élément de reconnaissance du travail
mais attention on est dans un pays où on
voit bien que le le regard l'attitude
portée vis-à-vis de tout ce qui est
politique que l'on soit un représentant
national ou local pourrait conduire
certains des maires à se se satisfaire
d'une revalorisation mais va contribuer
à alimenter un débat sur l'idée que ça y
est désormais les maires sont devenus
des professionnels de la politique et le
mot
professionnalisation peut à cou sûr
venir grignoter ce capital de confiance
qu'ont encore aujourd'hui les Français
vis-à-vis de leurs élus proximité ouais
il y a ça le fait que il pourrait être
perçu comme des professionnels de la
politique et est-ce que c'est pas
compliqué pour eux d'avoir ce débat sur
l'augmentation des indemnités en pleine
période d'inflation avec de plus en plus
de Français qui TER et c'est là où si
vous voulez on rejoint aussi
le le le le débat sur la
décentralisation parce que on essaie de
d'alléger le le millefeuille
administratif en fait on n'arrête pas de
le de le de
l'alourdir on voit qu'il y a un tas de
doublons dans l'organis tion
administrativ en France dans les
syndicats de communes tout ça là et et
en fait on s'aperçoit que ça aussi c'est
une façon pour les maire et bien de
d'améliorer l'ordinaire hein parce que
ils sont justement présidents de de de
de syndicat d'association de et ce qui
leur permet de d'arrondir les leur fin
de mois de de maire ou d'adjoint au
maire donc tout ça mériterait d'être vu
et corrigé moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent que c'est un véritable sacerdoce
hein de de de se lancer là-dedans dedans
euh parce que la considération n'existe
existe beaucoup moins euh la
satisfaction existe aussi beaucoup moins
et en plus vous êtes critiqué tout le
temps donc euh faut quand même le
vouloir faut du courage au terme de
cette enquête Alex quelles solutions
sont proposées pour par les maires
pardon pour lutter contre la crise
d'évocation et bien cela tourne beaucoup
autour de l'indemnité 20 % des maires
proposent d'augmenter l'indemnité des
élus 16 % souhaitent un fond d'aide de
l'État pour améliorer les conditions
d'exercice des mandats locaux et 14 %
proposeent d'augmenter la compensation
pour perte de revenus ouais mais il y a
pas que la question des des indemnités
martial ce qui ressort aussi de cette
enquête c'est euh une insatisfaction des
maires par rapport à l'état oui il y a
il y a j' il y a deux phénomènes il y en
a un qui continue de progresser et on
l'avait observé durant la crise covid on
avait beaucoup parlé du couple
magnifique ou supposément magnifique
entre le préfet et le maire bon la
situation en réalité elle est plus
nuancée cela euh parce que c'est des
relations interpersonnelles lorsque vous
avez un un préfet de département ou de
région euh innervé dans le tissu local
ça peut très très bien fonction mais
fonctionner mais vous savez qu'il y a le
principe de rotation de tout préfet ou
sous-préfet et beaucoup de mères se
plaignent de de ne pas être accompagné
c'est qu'ils ont des demandes on leur
dit vous devez trouver des ressources
euh répondez aux appels d'offre allez
chercher hein c'est l'expression allez
chercher les subventions bon ils ont
besoin parfois de d'ingénierie c'est le
terme qu'on emploie euh vis-à-vis de de
des services de l'État mais les services
de l'État disent mais nous on on on
n'est pas là pour élaborer les projets
pour vous nous on est là pour contrôler
les projets et alors ça crée des
situations euh totalement
incompréhensible entre les élus euh et
les services de l'État et puis un
deuxième sujet vis-à-vis de l'État c'est
je pense et c'est moins au niveau local
qu'au niveau national dans l'enquête on
voit bien que les maires se plaignent à
la fois d'un manque de reconnaissance on
l'a évoqué pour les cit citoyen mais au
fond c'est pas le plus grave c'est un
manque de reconnaissance de la parole
publique de la parole de l'exécutif
vis-à-vis des maires où ils nous disent
dans l'enquête on veut pas simplement
être mobilisé quand il y a une crise à
gérer mais on veut être écouté et on
veut être présent on veut finalement
être entendu pour l'élaboration des lois
pour le changement des rôles sur les
territoires et finalement c'est c'est ça
dont souffrent les maires aujourd'hui
c'est le sentiment que ils sont ils sont
un peu la la la 5è roue du carrosse et
quand il il y a une crise alors on
compte sur eux et ça finalement beaucoup
d'entre eux disent ça c'est plus
possible d'avoir cette relation
extrêmement déséquilibré
oui mais ça c'est je dirais que c'est un
vieux sujet en France hein justement
c'est justement le savoir si on est un
pays euh vous savez avec Emmanuel Macron
il y avait cette promesse d'un pacte
girondin hein c'est-à-dire que une plus
forte déconc
décentralisation une confiance
euh renouvelé et accentuer vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs locaux et puis finalement on
s'aperçoit que cette horizontalité n'a
pas existé que avec euh Emmanuel Macron
c'est la verticalité qui a qui a qui a
qui a eu pris le pouvoir euh c'est tout
le contraire de ce qu'il voulait faire
d'ailleurs c'est encore une fois un des
des reproches qu'on peut qu'on peut lui
faire ça lui a beaucoup été reproché au
début de son premier quinena aujourd'hui
il essae de euh de rectifier le tir mais
moi je constate une chose aussi vous
avez le Congrès des Maires quand même un
événement très important tous les ans
bah le président de la République qui a
assisté au début de son premier canquena
ne vient pas au Congrès des Maires ce
qui est pas normal le Congrès des Maires
c'est le pou de la France j'ai envie de
dire donc normalement le président de la
République devrait y assister un dernier
mot martial malgré tout ça tout ce dont
on a parlé les maires ils sont pas si
découragés que ça est-ce qu'il faut une
crise d'évocation pour
2026 c'est c'est très difficile parce
qu'on voit que les sujets de de
démission de non représentation varie de
contexte très
locaux je vais nuancer le propos sur
crise de voocation par deux exemples
très simples premièrement depuis les
trois dernières élections municipales 40
% des maires sont nouveaux donc il y a
bien un renouvellement de la démocratie
municipale donc ça ça tend à dire queil
y a pas une crise de vocation aussi aigu
que cela pourrait paraître aujourd'hui
depis deuxièement je rappelle la France
c'est le seul pays au monde certainement
dû à ce maillage de communes 35000
communes le seul pays au monde capable
de rassembler près de 1 million de
citoyens lors des élections municipales
950000 précisément qui vont s'inscrire
sur les listes pour battre campagne le
temps d'une élection municipale alors
s'il y avait véritablement une crise de
vocation nous aurions des centaines ou
des milliers de communes sans liste aux
élections municipales et ce n'est pas le
cas qui a en général c'est une
cinquantaine et ça permet d'alimenter
beaucoup de sujets dans la presse on va
terminer sur cette note d'optimisme on
continue à parler des merce à la une de
nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux Alex les maires font la Une de
plusieurs journaux régionaux et oui des
maires en résistance à la Une de corps
ce matin face à cette violence qui les
épuisent ils sont également à la Une du
journal breton le Télégramme les
violences faites au mer ce sera
malheureusement l'un des thèmes euh de
ce 105e congrès des maères de France qui
se tient cette semaine à Paris et qui
sera d'ailleurs à suivre chaque jour sur
Public Sénat depuis les dernières
élections municipal en 2020 1500 éedil
ont déjà démissionné face aux violences
en augmentation 15 % des mares éprouvent
un sentiment d'insécurité selon l'étude
du cvipof on parle éducation c'est à la
Une de l'Est Républicain avec des
parents en perte de confiance et oui
l'Est Républicain s'intéresse à ses
parents d'aujourd'hui qui cherchent de
plus en plus des méthodes d'expert en
parentalité et des cette miracle pour
éduquer leurs enfants en témoigne le
fort succès des livres sur la
parentalité en 2022 1,4 million de
livres sur ce sujets se sont vendus en
France avec un pic à 2 millions de
Vendes par an entre 2016 et 2018
auparavant on se mari on avait des
enfants c'était dans l'ordre des choses
explique la journaliste spécialisée
Béatrice camerer dans l'Est Républicain
et euh selon elle et bien aujourd'hui
avoir des enfants c'est un projet donc
les parents se sentent d'autant plus
responsables quittent à se mettre un peu
trop la pression et puis toujours dans
le journal l'Est Républicain j'ai
découvert un événement que je ne
connaissais pas la messe de la
saintthubert la messe des chiens de
chasse ce weekend elle était célébrée
dans le département de la Meuse dans les
ruines de la chapelle d'Orne détruite
par la bataille de Verdin en 1916 et de
nombreux maîtres et ont conduit leurs
chiens de chasse pour qu'ils soi bénis
par le père avaudé au son des corps de
chasse c'était un événement important un
passage obligé d'ailleurs pour les élus
hein ce weekend le sénateur de la Meuse
Franck Ménonville était présent à cette
messe de la s tuber Alex on termine avec
des locations de chambre pas comme les
autres et oui Var Matin consacre un
dossier du jour au succès des Love Room
dans le département du Var ce sont des
logements qui sont décorés et équipés
sur le thème de l'amour et du plaisir
pour redonner du piment dans le couple
et on peut les louer pour une nuit ou un
weekend alors c Love Room elle se
démocratise elle pulule notamment dans
le Var Var Matin a interrogé l'une de
ses clientes une trentenaire de Toulon
qui a essayé ses Love Room je la cite je
voulais un cadeau d'anniversaire
surprenant pour mon conjoint et je me
suis lancé nous avons dîner au champagne
et nous nous sommes redécouverts ce
moment à contribué à ranimer la femme et
à sortir du train train quotidien voilà
c'est c'est une idée merci Alex merci
beaucoup merci merci martial d'avoir été
avec nous et on suivra bien sûr cette
enquête tout au long de la semaine lors
de ce congrès des mes merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas pour sens public
et nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée